so we're here on the campus of UC
Berkeley where a number of groups have
organized to oppose fascism now
obviously the opposition as opposed to
fascism but before we can stop fascism
you have to stop the groups who are
stopping fascism the anti fascist is
also known as an Tifa I'm so sorry the
most destructive group in American life
right now is in these people are neo
communists that makes them the
equivalent of the neo-nazi deadly events
in charlottesville America six top
newspapers wisely spend equal time
condemning fascists and anti-fascists
fortunately the media knew that an Tifa
was just as dangerous and so did I so I
ventured into an anti impound slash
two-bedroom in Oakland to oppose them
face to face gentlemen thank you for
laying down your arms to meet me today
well thanks for having us great what
actions do you take is part of antifoam
the main goal of most anti-fur action is
to dissuade fascists and racists and
bigots from opening week practicing news
that we find repugnant on the streets
these are Bay Area Anti Fog members John
kook and Boo and Vincent yochelson which
are somehow real names stone-cold
killers how many people have you each
punched today I think I'm up to zero so
far how about you I am still at a rank
of zero you say you don't punch people I
did not say I don't punch people okay
son on the extreme right talk about a
concept of peaceful ethnic cleansing why
can't you just be peaceful like them
because they're not peaceful they're
followers and supporters show up with
violence I'm not interested in joining
your whiteness in the state do not bring
it to my house their House of Lies I
needed someone to talk real with me
real talk people who join on Tifa could
have easily joined you know the Richard
Spencer group a lot of these people are
just young guys looking for some action
Bloomberg columnist Eli Lake was part of
the media apparatus that knew that
anti-fascists had a whole lot in common
with the
grupe they were specifically named for
opposing that's why he calls an Tifa
also far which is also funny it's
absolutely true that that their violence
in both sides but I think a lot of
people are just there because it's like
a release it's exciting you treat it
like a you know Renaissance Fair like a
Star Trek convention or something it's a
LARPing situation little live-action
roleplay yeah that's exactly what it is
[Music]
we were out there protesting so if it's
so you let's say you guys are you and
I'm a knight of the ku klux klan
scenario that we might encounter because
i can't prepare for dragons these are
serious situations where there is the
potential for violence and injury and/or
death to people who are out there so
taking these protective measures is
necessary necessary like by any means
necessary like by murder how many people
has anti-shock killed and feel free to
round to the nearest hundred that would
be zero
are you rounding down professor mark
gray is a historian of anti-fascism his
ilk believes that just because
right-wing extremists are responsible
for 36 times more injuries than
left-wing ones that fascism is somehow
more dangerous than anti-fascism time
for this professor to get schooled by me
don't we want to stop Anti Fog before
they kill anyone it's always been my
belief that we have to stop violent
groups before they spread before they
get worse and this is the best example
of that I can think of I think a better
example are the fascist and white
supremacist groups that have a track
record of murder and that's exactly the
logic that anti-fascist put forward is
that it's much easier and more effective
to stop these groups before they grow
Hitler started with 54 so anti-fascist
argue let's stop it before it needs to
become another civil war
so you're saying a Hitler started with
54 people so an awkward group size you
know they can't can't off in someone's
house it's like you can't really book a
venue the anti-fascist kept bringing up
Hitler but in the words of Ice Cube
are we there yet I think you have to be
very precise we're not in a Hitler
moment one of the great mistakes from
World War two was fighting fascism too
hard too fast you agree that's nuts
no offense that's that's crazy no the
last end of World War two is that we
didn't find it soon enough when do you
know fascism has grown to the point that
a violent response is appropriate well
let me give me a second trick question
it's when there's Hitler and since I
haven't heard anyone speaking German
lately I knew I should be less worried
about these guys then these guys with
that in mind
I went back to try to stop an T for once
in her all and I would not leave until I
had succeeded I want you guys to stop
fascism by no longer fighting fascism no
negotiations have failed I had to create
some sort of auntie auntie a perfect
protest that no pundit could criticize
these black cloud and Tifa soldiers
would be no match for my whitewashed
movement after all the only group that
was worse than people trying to build a
fascist white ethno state are the people
trying to stop it
[Music]